let's bring in reggie miller hall of
famer turner sports nba
analyst reg what the heck happened last
night
well um to your point anthony davis has
to stay on the floor and stay out of
foul trouble
i think that contributed to marquis
morris
having more shot attempts is because
anthony
davis's butt was parked on the bench
because of that foul trouble
but you and i going back to the
beginning of the playoffs
said for the lakers to win a
championship a.d
has to be the best player over lebron on
the floor
and he was in those these first two
games
of the nba finals he gets in foul
trouble now you
if you're frank vogel you kind of go to
plan b to try to
you know mix and match your
you know your team and your effort and
again let's give miami the credit in
jimmy butler because they played
spectacular
and living here in la i know people
think the sky is falling because the
lakers lost
with the heat missing two starters and
draggage
and bam out of bio but it's one game
and what you're telling me is for jimmy
butler to have a 40-point triple-double
kelly olynyk played great and made shots
and they still scratch and claw to win
that game
they would have to play like that the
rest of the way to beat the lakers
that's why
this is not that big of a deal it's one
game
where the sky was falling when they lost
to houston
game one the sky was falling when they
lost to portland game one would they
go on to do win four straight so i'm not
worried about that they're still up to
one in the series
and now with all this negative press
coming towards lebron and what's wrong
with a.d
he may have lost his final wp chances
all this is going to do
is is really tick off the lakers and
we'll see a much better performance in
game four
what if you read an article that just
said hey you know what
acknowledge the heat jimmy butler great
performance
and uh you know lebron's gonna win his
fourth title
and anthony davis going to be the mvp
nobody is writing that
even though deep down they probably feel
that but
jimmy butler after lebron says to him in
the first quarter you're in trouble
and then jimmy butler comes back in the
fourth quarter and says to lebron
you're in trouble that's
i mean i love that
isn't it great i mean i mean you this is
your two superstars going at one another
which
normally doesn't happen you know
normally
you pick on other guys that you know you
can kind of get in their heads
but jimmy butler responding to the king
which i love
um but again
without two starters and not knowing if
bam is going to be available
in game four i i really don't see gorham
coming back with a torn planner
bash it who knows depends on how how big
the tear is
maybe he comes back i'm not really sure
but how effective can he be on that
so if you're still going to be without
two starters
you've got to play like this the rest of
the way out
and if you're going to tell me that
jimmy butler is going to average a
triple double and 40 points on it that's
not his dna
that's not what has made the heat so
successful to get to this final of rum
finals run they were everyone was
collectively
involved hiro duncan jay crowder those
guys played
effective last night not great but
effective and
they rolled the shoulders of the hot man
which just so happened
to be jimmy butler but that's not him
it's just not him
and he didn't even take a three-pointer
jimmy butler
put up 40 and didn't take a
three-pointer what what what's wrong
with jimmy butler doesn't he realize you
have to shoot threes in the nba to be
good
and i think the lakers they they got
away what made them so successful in
games one and two
they pounded the heat inside they
killed them with points in the paint
they used their size to the advantage
last night it was almost like they
morphed into the houston rockets
like they had to jack up a whole bunch
of threes and that's not their game
and you're right jimmy butler but if you
look at his stats
all season he hasn't taken a lot of
threes he's not
a great three-pointer shoot a shooter he
can make them
but he would much rather put pressure on
you
on your interior defense get fouled on
those drives and go to the free-throw
line
he's reggie miller joining us uh kyrie
irving said on
kevin durant's new podcast that he
finally has a guy he can trust in the
clutch at the end of games
then kyrie said why is everybody kind of
you know saying this is me calling out
lebron
why's it always got to be brother and
brother here but by
acknowledging kd he finally has that
clutch guy
he is calling out lebron is not being
that clutch guy in my opinion
well i don't know again we're piling on
lebron
you know it's no no i'm piling on kyrie
kyrie but lebron gets
kind of dragged into it don't you think
well all he has to say is
it's great to have another clutch player
with me
because then that's real that's honest
i think that's what he's i think that's
if you really know he says
that that's the i finally have i finally
have a clutch shooter i can count on
come on again he but he is right on that
because
kevin durant is a great shooter
lebron james is not a great shooter is
he clunky
i think lebron is clutch yes yes the
numbers show that he's clutch
kyrie has made one big shot in his
career
but that's a pretty big shot that he
made that doesn't make you clutch
if you hit one reg
i think kyrie is clutch as well i think
at the end of closing games kyrie knows
how to take over because of his ball
handling and his score
who's more clutch lebron or kyrie
well stats would say lebron yeah because
lebron's been around that's the answer
because kyrie can't stay healthy either
that's true
you can't be clutch if you're not on the
floor again
i think he was more so trying to pump up
kd his teammate
as they get ready for next year and i
think he was
i don't think he was trying to throw
shade at lebron though it probably came
off that way because again
lebron's an easy target and we're in the
finals and it's all about
what the lakers will do or will not do
and i just think it was an easy target
and then kyrie says that steve nash is
not really
the head coach that sometimes kyrie is
going to be the head coach
and sometimes k.d is going to be the
head coach but he didn't
view steve nash as their head coach well
see that's where i think they may run
into problems because you do
and you still have young players on that
team spencer dinwiddie
carouse so
with that young coupled team and
teammates
and you've got these established
veterans who've won championships and kd
and kyrie
you hope it doesn't come off like we're
running the organization here
we're going to be calling all the plays
and you guys fall in line
i hope steve nash look i know it's a
collaborative effort
because i've helped a lot of my coaches
along the way and certain things are
what's working on the court and what's
not working on the court but the end of
the day you got to respect
that's my coach he's going to draw what
he feels is right
for us not me for us to win and be
successful
but those two katie and kyrie may feel
like they
are running this team because they're
the ones that signed off on steve nash
becoming the head coach so
they're they do have power a lot and a
lot of it and again they have the rings
to back it up but
i just think at times it can send a bad
message if you're saying
yeah i mean he's the de facto coach but
really
you know we're going to be giving you
your plane minutes i mean that's not
going to be the case
oh i know what's happening i know what's
happening
you're sticking up for kyrie because he
puts you in the movie
and if they if they do a sequel to uncle
i get it i get it i get it i get it
uncle drew two yeah the return of lights
yeah i get up
no stop that is there going to be a
sequel to uncle drill
no because there's no way i'm going to
sit in that chair for four and a half
hours
for me ever again because normally you
sit in there for three hours
to scare the producers from calling me
and saying i'm not going to be sitting
in a chair for four hours
though that movie will go down as a
class
some of the lines in there are hilarious
and i appreciate all you guys coming to
the premiere as well
and that's where kd sat right behind us
katie's not even in the movie and and oh
boy when i'm with the dan edson i went
something's up here right he came as a
guest
of kyrie why didn't we put it together
then
we did we just had nobody who would
listen to us we're like
whoa kd coming with for kyrie
uh doc going to the 76ers what do you
think
i think if i'm joel embiid and
ben simmons i better get my act straight
right no more deflecting that it's coach
brown and his fault
i gotta look at myself in the mirror and
get my game in order and
you were already expected to win and
compete in the eastern conference which
you laid it down
at the restart so now the pressure is on
my two stars it just feels like it's a
younger version of the clippers
they still need some help they need some
outside shooting
yeah but where do we find out everybody
goes yeah we could do some outside
shooting yeah
i don't know look you still have harris
who i think is
a capable shooter at times and score
tobias harris
um they have matisse steiple the young
player out of
washington but other than that they have
no bench then they got al horford still
they look they their starting five is
decent it's good
they can compete with you it's when they
go to the bench and who knows maybe doc
and along with elton brand who's the
general manager they can kind of revamp
that bench area but
look i i was upset to see doc leave the
clippers i thought
he he should have remained there and
gave it another go
but changes changes are all around us
every day
so you're calling for the lakers to take
the next two and then it's over
i think so the sky is not far it's one
game
but i will say this all bets are off
if miami obviously ties us up 2-2
because now what's coming into play
is when you extend series and you gotta
go extra game
tweak up an ankle i mean look what
happened to bam and look what happened
to goron draggage
you know someone can go down on the
lakers and it just changes
the complexity of a series take care of
business when you've got to be able to
take care of business
if this comes out 2-2 uh tomorrow
all bets are off miami has a legitimate
shot to win this what are you going to
miss about the bubble
probably the solitude you know i was it
was finally getting one
with my thoughts you know stayed one in
your you get to stay in your room
and netflix and hulu became my best
friends and
that's probably what i'm gonna miss the
solitude i don't have you know kids
kids be quiet i don't have any of that
though i miss my boogers it was nice and
quiet got a lot of sleep mama bear
didn't like that
i got a lot of sleep you know
a funny story because this is what would
happen she would facetime me
and i'd be in bed just like laying
covers all up slobber coming down so
every time she would facetime me i would
hurry up and get up and go into the
front room
put on my glasses and act like i was
studying because i didn't want her to
know that i was like sleepy
because i felt bad that i was able to
get sleep
if she wasn't every time she would
facetime i'd run into the other room
and act like i was working she's like
hey what are you doing
over numbers getting ready for you know
i remember being at the nba finals and
you're on the road for like three weeks
and whenever i would call in
to my wife and we had four kids under
the age of seven
so i always you know
i always i hope that she wouldn't answer
and i could leave a message
because chances are she'd say uh what
are you doing for dinner and i'd go oh
i'm going to mastro's steakhouse
and then you know i'd say well what are
you having uh we're having leftovers
chef boyardee you know spaghettios
oh i felt horrible i feel so bad like
what do you have i'm like
i'm gonna go get a filet mignon yeah
i felt that so i said that once and i
was like you know what are you doing
yeah oh yeah uh good to talk to you
and uh regis red says it's over
it's over the miami heat are going to go
down in flames again
but let me just say at the start of this
who did i pick to win in seven
the heat but without two starters and
not knowing if bam's gonna be effective
in game four
this is too much for jimmy as great as
he was phenomenal
love you jimmy uncle jimmy as we call
him in our household
it's it's too much to bear unless unless
miami goes crazy from the three-point
line if they can average
16 17 threes a game they can make it a
series
thank you reg you're the best theater
i love y'all that's reggie aloysius
miller junior iii